Economists generally think it's okay for debt...
...to increase when the economy needs a boost.
You can see in this chart...
...federal debt held by the public spiked during World War II...
...and during the financial crisis,...
...when the government borrowed money to boost the economy.
The problem is that the federal debt is set to continue...
...to increase to its highest level since 1946,...
...even though the economy is now in much better shape.
The Tax Cuts and Jobs Act is passed.
One reason for this is a big law Congress passed at the end of 2017...
...that lowered taxes without cutting spending,...
...which will result in even more borrowing.
Another reason the national debt is likely to grow?
America's population is getting older.
And that means the government...
...will need to pay for more programs for its senior citizens.
For example, spending will increase on Medicare, Medicaid and social security.